[Musique]
bonsoir à tous j'ai une fille qui a 12
ans je me souviens d'une promenade avec
elle que j'ai pu faire il ya quelques
années sur le port de plaisance de caen
elle avait 5 ans à l'époque ma fille et
moi je venais de passer une semaine
assez chargé au niveau de mon travail je
savais que la semaine suivante allait
être chargé également donc je le disais
que cette promenade allait être
l'occasion de se détendre et j'avais
raison c'était le cas je me souviens que
je voyais le les mâts des bateaux qui
oscillait ensemble sous l'effet d'un
petit vente fin de journée qui vient
rafraîchir l'air c'était vraiment
agréable avec une lumière également qu'
qui diminuait sur la ville c'était
vraiment très très jolie vraiment le
cadre idéal pour me reposer l'esprit et
je tenais la main de ma petite fille de
cinq ans qui elle aussi profité de cette
petite promenade avec moi mais ils en
profiter à sa façon elle me faisait
profiter
il est papa tu as vu la coque du bateau
et les jaunes puis regarde en haut du
mât il ya un drapeau bleu blanc rouge
c'est le drapeau de la france salue je
connais bien qui ont marché encore un
petit peu déployé un caillou c'est un
galet on peut faire des ricochets pile
monsieur là bas il est une moustache il
est marrant en fait on était au même
endroit au même moment
mais on ne profitait pas du tout de la
promenade de la même façon pourquoi
pourquoi ma fille se focaliser sur les
détails de l'environnement visuel alors
que moi je profitais de l'ensemble de la
scène pour répondre à cette question je
vais vous proposer de passer une petite
expérience avec moi une expérience de
psychologie expérimentale
vous avez vu apparaître sur l'écran des
grands x former de petits hics alors je
vais vous demander de porter votre
attention sur les grands x d'accord donc
fait tous bien attention aux grands x et
je vais remplacer ces lettres par
d'autres lettres et je vais vous
demander de me dire quelle lettre vous
voyez donc les grandes lettres
alors je vais présenter rapidement ses
lettres parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir ce qui se passe dans les
premières étapes de traitement de
l'information visuelle par votre cerveau
alors tout le monde est prêt
ouais donc les trois grands x regardez
bien
et dites moi quelle lettre sont
présentés on y va super très bien donc
maintenant on va passer à la deuxième
partie de l'expérience
cette fois ci je vous demande de vous
focaliser sur les détails
c'est à dire des petits hics hockey tout
le monde voit les petits hics c'est bon
alors on fait la même chose je vous les
présente rapidement ces lettres et vous
m'indiquer ce que vous voyez les petites
lettres on y va alors j'ai entendu le g
très bien et j'ai entendu quelques s il
n'y avait pas de s en fait là cette
petite expérience où vous informe de la
façon dont votre cerveau d'adultes
fonctionne la première tâche aux ailes
c'était très homogène dans la salle tout
le monde a réussi pas de problème
la deuxième tâche finalement c'est un
petit peu plus dur ce qui vous prouve
que votre cerveau fonctionne de façon
globale en général c'est vous percevez
en priorité l'information globale
c'est pour ça que pour la deuxième tâche
comme on lit de gauche à droite le et le
g ça a été à peu près et puis le sait
est passé un petit peu à la trappe
parce que votre cerveau n'a pas eu le
temps de bloquer en psychologie qu on
appelle ça de l'inhibition il a pas eu
tant d'inhiber le grand s pour répondre
c est donc vous avez eu plus de mal a
indiqué ed c'est d'ailleurs il y avait
un grand sos peut-être qu'il vous a gêné
et le messrs étaient aussi présents dans
la première tâche si vous regardez bien
il y avait un petit sos vous le
découvrirez peut-être maintenant
en fait il était présent aussi ce que ça
vous montre comment le cerveau d'adultes
fonctionne vous traiter en priorité
l'information globale ce qui se passait
pour moi sur le port de plaisance de
caen
si je fais passer la même expérience un
enfant de 4 ans ou 5 ans on obtiendra
les résultats complètement inverse les
enfants de 4-5 ans vont se focaliser sur
les détails et auront de meilleures
performances pour détecter les petites
lettres que les grandes
alors que se passe-t-il dans le cerveau
de ces enfants pour le découvrir on peut
utiliser l'irm
l'irm est une technique qui permet
d'étudier le développement du cerveau et
dans mon laboratoire de l'abside et qui
est dirigée par le professeur grégoire
borst
nous avons eu l'occasion d'étudier ce
développement cérébral à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici en fait à caen
dans un centre d'imagerie cérébrale qui
s'appelle cicéron et la chance que l'on
a eue c'est de pouvoir aménager cette
salle et l'adapter pour accueillir des
enfants de cinq six ans donc des petits
collègues qui venait de dizaines
d'écoles de l'agglomération caennaise et
qui sont venus faire de la recherche
avec nous en partenariat avec la
direction académique du calvados et on a
pu étudier le développement de leur
cerveau est ce que vous voyez ici c'est
ce qui se passe dans le cerveau d'un
enfant de six ans qui lui permet
d'accéder à l'environnement global il ya
l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle un
réseau et ce réseau comprend
principalement deux régions une région
occipitale à l'arrière du cerveau c'est
ce qui vous permet de voir une région un
petit peu plus en hauteur dans le lobe
pariétal qui vous permet de faire
attention aux informations visuelles et
donc ce réseau occipitaux pariétal dans
l'hémisphère droit va permettre à
l'enfant
après son sixième anniversaire de
percevoir l'information globale comme le
fait un adulte
si ce réseau ne se met pas en place
correctement
on va rester focalisé sur les détails
c'est ce qui peut se passer par exemple
chez un enfant autiste
alors pourquoi le cerveau à temps
pourquoi le cerveau humain il faut
attendre six ans pour que ce réseau se
met en place
l'hypothèse que l'on peut faire est très
adaptative on se dit que l'enfant dans
ses premières années de vie découvre le
monde des objets et pour découvrir le
monde est bien une technique visuel
locales et plus efficace on va découvrir
les particularités des objets leur
fonction ça c'est plus efficace de le
faire quand on se focalise sur les
détails plus avec l'âge en fait le les
connaissances s'élargissent et le focus
attentionnel s'élargit également et on
va pouvoir apprécier le monde de façon
globale alors si on résume
si je présente cette part tueur
d'arcimboldo un enfant de 4 ans ou cinq
ans il va indiquer qu'on voit des fruits
des légumes des fleurs vers 5-6 ans
l'enfant me dira ce sont des fruits des
légumes des fleurs et ça fait une tête
de bonhomme voyez commence à percevoir
l'information globale vous pouvez
essayer chez vous et après six ans
cet enfant lundi grasset une tête de
bonhomme qui est faite de fruits de
légumes de fleurs vous voyez on a une
inversion de cette dynamique de
perception visuelle avec l'âge est en
fait cette évolution elle va être
influencé par certains facteurs comme
les motions l'émotion influence notre
perception visuelle dans mon histoire de
ma promenade sur le port de caen si
j'avais entendu un crissement de pneus
de voiture eh bien on se rend compte que
mon faisceau attentionnel ce serait
resserré sur les détails pour savoir
d'où vient le danger
donc on est influencé par nos émotions
c'est lié au fait qu'on a des connexions
entre des régions cérébrales qui gère
les émotions qu'on appelle les amygdales
qui sont connectés avec l'arrière du
cerveau dans le cortex visuel occipital
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure il
va chez l'enfant c'est pareil un enfant
qui est dans un état émotionnel négatif
va se focaliser six paires focaliser sur
les détails et un enfant qui est dans un
état émotionnel positif va pouvoir
élargir son focus intentionnel et ça
c'est très important dans le domaine de
l'éducation et de la pédagogie
parce que tous les enfants qui arrivent
à l'école le matin ne sont pas tous dans
le même état émotionnel
par contre on va leur montrer à tous les
mêmes informations visuelles
quand on leur présente des petits
exercices à résoudre
donc ça veut dire que tous ces enfants
ne vont pas profiter finalement des
informations visuelles qu'on leur
communique
selon l'état émotionnel dans lequel ils
sont donc l'objectif des recherches
actuelles c'est de réussir à faire
profiter des enfants afin d'optimiser
finalement leur traitement visuel et ça
on sait le faire quelques petites
séances d'entraînement de quelques
minutes par jour quelques jours par
semaine sur tablette tactile par exemple
on va leur apprendre à inhiber à bloquer
des informations qui ne sont pas
pertinentes et se focaliser sur ce qui
est important comme apprendre à bloquer
le grand est tout à l'heure qui vous a
tous un petit peu gêné
on peut apprendre à faire ça ça on y
arrive maintenant
mais alors faut-il voir le monde avec
des yeux d'enfants à mon avis la vente
âge c'est d'être capable d'osciller
entre les deux types de traitements être
capable de traiter les détails quand on
veut découvrir un objet et puis on a vu
que traiter l'environnement
façon globale c'est plutôt apaisant
c'est plutôt agréable
en revanche tout ce que je vous ai
indiqué sur la perception visuelle chez
l'enfant est valable aussi sur sa façon
de penser l'enfant pense le monde de
façon locale l'enfant se focalise sur
l'instant présent
les enfants ne s'inquiète pas du passé
il n'anticipe pas l'avenir c'est ce que
l'on appelle une pensée par état est-ce
que je vous invite à faire ce n'est pas
de voir le monde avec des yeux d'enfant
mais de penser le monde avec des yeux
d'enfants moi c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire le plus souvent possible avec ma
fille de 12 ans et je vous laisse y
réfléchir avant votre prochaine
promenade sur le port de caen merci pour
votre relation
[Musique]